now to this the reopening of our country
got many businesses who are struggling
to hire employees as the pandemic
restrictions are
suddenly rescinded why because many
can't resist unemployment checks they
are deciding to stay home
and not work even though their jobs are
being offered my next guest has some
advice
for many americans who aren't going back
yet because they're concerned
or they want to get a check for doing
nothing jaco wilnik retired navy seal
leadership speaker one of the best in
the business
and author of many children's books way
of the warrior kid and mikey and the
dragons
jocko what is your advice to americans
who have gone through this trauma over
the last year
and say i'm really concerned about going
back to work do you understand that
well of course you're concerned you're
worried but guess what
take a look around take a look at states
that are already open back
up there's no real big negative impacts
in fact no negative impacts at all
people are leading the way courageous
people are stepping out and making it
happen
it's time to follow their lead all right
the jobs are open go grab that job even
if in the short term you might have
gotten more for staying home just do the
right thing
the other thing that's happened in this
country i want you to weigh in on is a
big push to say america built on slavery
1619.
we fought 1776 to keep slavery the facts
really belie these new courses and this
new academic push
what's your reaction to a man who shed
blood for this country
about patriotism and the red white and
blue
well look we shouldn't hide anything
from our children and we need to teach
them we need to teach them
the full truth you know not not just
that america was an
active participant in the evil
institution of slavery
but also that america fought to abolish
slavery that 360
000 union soldiers were killed in that
war and that
more than 10 of those soldiers over 40
000 killed
were african-americans many of them
freed slaves themselves
who also fought for america and fought
for freedom to end slavery
we need to teach the bad and the ugly
for sure
but we also need to teach the good as
well and there's plenty of it to teach
jaco that's true and it made you put on
the face paint and the camouflage and go
and fight these wars and come back
and spread the leadership's principles
to people who wear a suit for a living
but what attracted you to this country
when did you realize how special this
place was
well look america is a is a country
that's built on ideals
right it's not it's not a country that's
built on on race or on bloodlines it's
built on the ideals
of freedom and i think we owe it to each
new generation
to teach them to love those ideals the
ideals of america
especially more than they love their
bloodlines or they love
their skin color that is not america
it's not america
when you go overseas and come back and
you fight for the country
what's the response for example when
you're fighting afghanistan and iraq
for those who understand what you're
made of and what your fellow americans
are made of
well look when i served in the military
i served along
every race alongside every race every
color every creed
with men and women from the most diverse
imaginable socio-economic backgrounds
from all over the country
and we in the military set those
differences aside
in fact what we do is we find common
ground in the very flag
we wore on our sleeves and carried into
battle
the flag that was draped over the coffin
of our fallen
friends we are americans and we can't
forget that
and we can't allow politics or
government or education or media
to drive us apart we have to remain
united in freedom and i think that's
what we need to teach our children
are you worried this country's gone soft
i work with the military still and i see
those young
soldiers sailors airmen and marines
they're not soft
they're ready to defend this great
country why was it important for you
a guy that has seen so much and been
through so much to write books to set
the ground rules maybe for kids
and give them some guidelines well i
have four kids of my own
and i wanted to write books where they
could get the kind of values that i
wanted them to get
discipline and hard work and treating
people with respect and
the importance of knowledge and the
importance of education and
patience and being helpful and and
tenacity
and learning about being a leader as a
kid i wanted to pass those values on
not just to my kids but to all the kids
in this great country now you know why
everyone downloads this podcast jaco
podcast i appreciate it we'll be
thinking about you and i know you will
come this memorial day and you'll be on
with us again jaco thanks so much for
making the time
out on the west coast thanks for having
me hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now